So how many years were you an executioner in your job?
你做这份工作时，担任了多少年的刽子手？
That period lasted for maybe five or six years.
那段时期大概持续了五六年。
That's a really long time.
那是非常长的时间了。
Oh it was a very long time. It was very, very depressing.
噢，那确实是非常长的一段时间。那段日子非常、非常压抑。
Chris is a mild-mannered, decent guy who was an executioner in the sense that he fired over 1,500 people. He was working for a financial services firm. And the internet boom went bust, 9/11 happened, the economy was bad, business was terrible. And as a result, call centers with hundreds of people were barely getting any calls. And when the company downsized, he had to see that all of these people, hundreds of them, were dismissed. And then at the end of the process, he was fired.
克里斯是一个温和、体面的家伙，他担任“刽子手”的意思是他解雇了超过1500人。他在一家金融服务公司工作。当时互联网泡沫破裂，9/11事件发生，经济低迷，业务惨淡。结果，拥有数百名员工的呼叫中心几乎接不到电话。当公司裁员时，他不得不亲眼看着所有这些人，数百名员工，被解雇。而在整个过程结束后，他自己也被解雇了。
The whole unit I was in at that time, the organization decided that they were going to fold that unit and not be in that business directly.
当时我所在的整个部门，组织决定裁撤该部门，不再直接从事相关业务。
So did you have to fire yourself? Was it like a samurai movie, where they gave you an order saying you will execute all these people and then you will execute yourself?
所以你是得解雇你自己吗？这就像武士电影里那样，他们给你下令说你将处决所有人，然后你再处决你自己？
No, it wasn't that way. Pretty much all of us took a turn. We were all in the wrong seat eventually. I'd say 90% of us, anyway.
不，不是那样的。我们所有人基本上都轮到了。最终我们都坐错了位置。我想我们中大概有90%的人都是这样。
You might notice that in my conversation with Chris, I use the word executioner, but he never does. He is such an old school human resources guy. So old school that decades ago, he was actually part of a group that helped popularize the phrase human resources department, replacing the term personnel department, which means that he is much too smooth, and experienced, and truly empathetic to ever use the word executioner. Or the word fired for that matter.
你可能会注意到，在我和克里斯的谈话中，我用了“刽子手”这个词，但他从不使用。他是一个非常老派的人力资源从业者。老派到几十年前，他实际上是推广“人力资源部”这个词组、取代“人事部”这一称呼的团队成员之一。这意味着他太圆滑、太资深，也太富有同情心，绝不会使用“刽子手”这个词。或者说“解雇”这个词也是如此。
I would never use it. I think that's something that-- I think that's an unhelpful and kind of a dated concept. If you've done it skillfully, they're going to feel that there was a parting of the ways, there was an exit of the unit, or whatever the factors are. I know when I received a package, I came through the door and said, "Hey, I've been exited. I got a package. They're closing down the unit." And I hadn't actually thought of myself as being fired for a second.
我绝不会用那个词。我认为那是一个……我觉得那是一个毫无助益且有些过时的概念。如果你处理得当，他们会感觉到双方是分道扬镳，或者是部门撤裁，或者不管是什么原因。我知道当我拿到赔偿金时，我走进门说：“嘿，我被撤职了。我拿到了赔偿金。他们要关闭这个部门。”我甚至一秒钟都没有想过自己是被解雇了。
This is a very positive, glass half full kind of man. So it was sort of miserable for him during those five or six years, flying around the country, checking into hotels and then planning what he was going to say to certain people. Preparing himself to go into these big call centers to arrange for hundreds of people to be fired at one time.
这是一个非常积极、总是看到事物光明面的男人。所以在那五六年里，对他来说那段经历相当痛苦，他要飞往全国各地，办理酒店入住，然后计划要对特定的人说什么。他得准备好走进这些大型呼叫中心，安排数百人同时被解雇。
Well it feels bad, obviously. And it's a painful thing. Many people had grown up there for years. And this was their life as well as their role and their job. And before you get there, they know. I mean the jungle drums are out there. And you walk into a call center, there isn't a receptionist. You walk down the halls and past the desks, and people will kind of look at you.
嗯，这显然感觉很不好。这是一件令人痛苦的事情。许多人在那里工作多年，已经成长起来。这不仅是他们的角色和工作，更是他们的生活。在你到达之前，他们就知道了。我是说消息已经传开了。你走进呼叫中心，没有接待员。你走过大厅，经过办公桌，人们会用那种眼神看你。
Did you ever actually hear people say, as you walked by, here they come?
当你走过时，你是否真的听到人们说“他们来了”？
That's happened, yes. I've had people say, is this the executioner? It's not-- you know they're wondering, is it going to be me? How's it going to impact my life?
发生过，是的。我遇到过有人问：“这是刽子手吗？”那不是……你知道他们是在想，会是我吗？这会如何影响我的生活？
So just to be clear, so you've personally fired dozens of people and then overseen the firing of hundreds of people, right?
那么明确一下，你亲自解雇了几十个人，然后监督了数百人的解雇，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
OK, can I ask you to just fire me right now?
好的，我可以请你现在就解雇我吗？
OK, OK. Hi, Ira. How are you?
好的，好的。嗨，艾拉。你好吗？
I'm doing OK.
我挺好的。
Good, good. Ira, this is going to be a difficult conversation. I want to let you know that up front. You know we've been going through serious changes in the market environment over the last 12, 18 months. And so the organization, I think as you know, is making some decisions to downsize. And I have the bad news for you, which is that you're part of that downsizing. So you know your role--
很好，很好。艾拉，这将是一次艰难的谈话。我想先让你知道这一点。你知道我们过去12到18个月里市场环境发生了重大变化。所以组织，我想你也知道，正在做出一些裁员的决定。我有一个坏消息要告诉你，那就是你也在这次裁员名单中。所以你知道你的职位……
As Chris did this, from the moment that he said this is going to be a difficult conversation, I feel like he got the message across. I was going to be fired. And then even though I knew this was made up, my mind went blank. His language was so abstract and businessy that it just let my mind kind of wander and think, "Oh, I've been fired. I've been fired. What am I going to do now?" And then next thing  I knew, he was talking about my severance package.
当克里斯这样做时，从他说“这将是一次艰难的谈话”的那一刻起，我觉得他就已经传达了信息。我要被解雇了。尽管我知道这是演戏，但我脑子还是空白了。他的语言如此抽象和商务化，以至于我的思绪不禁游离，心想：“噢，我被解雇了。我被解雇了。我现在该怎么办？”然后我回过神时，他正在谈论我的遣散费。
And I'd like to tell you a little bit about the support that we're going to provide for you in terms of salary continuation, and medical coverage, and things like that.
我想向你介绍一下我们将为你提供的支持，包括工资延续、医疗保险之类的。
So when Chris was done firing me, I asked him about how clinical his language had been, if that was a technique of some sort, to lull me into accepting my firing.
所以当克里斯解雇完我后，我问他，他那种公事公办的语言是否是一种技巧，是为了让我平静地接受被解雇的事实。
It just comes out that way because you start with the facts. And you also need to be careful about what you say. So you don't want to enrage the person on a personal level. So you really want to keep it calm and talk much more about their exit package.
这只是自然而然说出来的，因为你要从事实出发。而且你需要小心你的措辞。你不想让对方在个人层面上暴怒。所以你真的需要保持冷静，多谈谈他们的离职补偿。
Now, did you get nervous as you were doing that?
那么，你在做这些的时候会紧张吗？
Sure.
当然。
You sounded a little nervous. And also I have to say, I am sitting here at a mixing console, so I'm controlling the volume of your voice. The volume of your voice cut in half. I've been pushing up the volume of your voice steadily the entire time.
你听起来确实有点紧张。而且我必须说，我正坐在这控制混音台，所以我控制着你声音的大小。你的声音音量减小了一半。我一直在稳步调高你的音量。
It's not a comfortable thing. It's not a comfortable thing.
这并不是一件舒服的事情。这并不是一件舒服的事情。
Even for you.
即使是对你来说。
No. It's never comfortable. It's something, I don't think-- you can do it 100 times and it still feels bad. And I think it's because at the end of the day, people have much less control than organizations do in the world of work. The actual job finding processes are still pretty antiquated for individuals, whereas organizations can have recruiters and search firms, and advertise, and et cetera, et cetera. An individual, they're kind of like a little boat in a big sea. And they're going to bob around there. And they're going to have to scratch together a living again.
不。从来都不舒服。我不认为……你可以做100次，但感觉依然不好。我想这是因为归根结底，在职场世界中，个人的掌控力远不如组织。实际的找工作流程对个人来说仍然相当过时，而组织可以有招聘人员、猎头公司、发布广告等等。个人就像大海中的一叶扁舟。他们不得不随波逐流。他们必须再次挣扎着谋生。
The company always has more power than we do. And if we're lucky, they manage us well, they're fair, they keep us busy enough but not too busy. But we are not always lucky. Today on our show we have stories about how our lives get run by these institutions. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira  Glass.
公司永远比我们拥有更多的权力。如果我们幸运的话，他们会很好地管理我们，他们是公平的，让他们忙碌程度适中。但我们并不总是那么幸运。今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述我们的生活如何被这些机构所掌控的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ，《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际公司分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our program today, Human Resources, in three acts. Act One, The Rubber Room. In that act, hundreds of public school teachers who are not in the classroom but who get paid full salaries to do nothing. Act Two, The Plan. The secret cabal who may or may not run real estate markets all over the country. Act Three, Almost Human Resources. Human management of animals has gotten to the point where even the federal government has started to build animals retirement homes. No kidding. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目《人力资源》，分为三幕。第一幕，橡皮室。在这一幕中，数百名公立学校教师虽然不在教室上课，但却拿着全额工资无所事事。第二幕，计划。可能在全国范围内掌控房地产市场的神秘阴谋集团。第三幕，近乎人力资源。对动物的人力管理已经到了连联邦政府都开始为动物建立退休之家的地步。没开玩笑。请继续收听。
Act One, Rubber Room. A former schoolteacher named Jeremy Garrett decided to make a movie about one of the things the school system puts his colleagues through, something that seemed like terrible mismanagement to him in the New York City public schools where he worked. Jeremy had heard about teachers who were removed from their classrooms and sent to a place that everybody calls the rubber room. Like for example this teacher that he interviewed, who did not want his name used. He was having personality conflicts with the principal. And the principal suggested that he could be reassigned elsewhere. It sounded great to the teacher. And then for the next few days, instead of going to school, he went to this room in a Department of Education building.
第一幕，橡皮室。一位名叫杰里米·加勒特的前学校教师决定拍一部电影，讲述学区让他同事经历的事情之一，这对他来说，在他工作的纽约市公立学校中，似乎是可怕的管理不善。杰里米听说过一些教师被从教室移除，并被送到一个每个人都称之为“橡皮室”的地方。比如他采访的这位不想透露姓名的老师。他与校长发生了人格冲突。校长建议他可以被调往别处。这听起来对老师来说很棒。然后接下来的几天，他没有去学校，而是去了教育局大楼里的这个房间。
It's kind of embarrassing. The first two days as I'm sitting down there, I was naive enough to say to the secretary, about what time do you think I'll be meeting with somebody? And she's like, well, you're just going to sit there until you do meet with somebody. And then at the end of the second day, I'm like, this is crazy. I mean, I have an after school Regents Prep program to help the kids with the Regents Exam. I'm like, this is nuts. These kids have to take a Regents Exam. They're like a week away. And then eventually the light goes on over your head as you start meeting other people that are sitting there too. And you realize, all right, this is going to be a long term kind of thing.
这有点尴尬。前两天我坐在那里，我天真地问秘书：“你觉得我大概什么时候会和某人见面？”她说：“嗯，你就坐在那里，直到你见到某人为止。”然后在第二天结束时，我想，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，我有一个放学后的 Regents 预备项目来帮助孩子们应对 Regents 考试。我想，这太荒谬了。这些孩子下周就要参加考试了。然后最终，当你开始见到也坐在那里的其他人时，你恍然大悟。你意识到，好吧，这会是一种长期的情况。
This is the rubber room. Some teachers are put there because they are accused of something like putting their hands on a kid, where the school would want them out of the classroom while it investigates and determines guilt or innocence. But many of the teachers are just there for things like insubordination, unsatisfactory performance. And some teachers don't know why they're there. And instead of finding them guilty and firing them, or finding them innocent and returning them to the classroom, the New York schools just hold them, sometimes for years, doing nothing-- nothing. All day long, nothing-- in these big rooms.
这就是橡皮室。一些老师被安置在那里是因为他们被指控诸如对孩子动粗之类的罪名，学校希望在调查并确定是否有罪之前将他们移出教室。但许多老师只是因为诸如抗命、表现不达标等原因被关在那里。有些老师甚至不知道他们为什么会在那里。纽约的学校没有判定他们有罪并解雇他们，也没有判定他们无罪并让他们回到教室，只是把他们关在那里，有时长达数年，什么都不做——什么都不做。整天，什么都不做——在这些大房间里。
The environment has a culture all its own. And when you're there long enough-- like I was there for a year. When you're there long enough, you see the stages of the culture. New people sit there, and are very quiet, and say nothing to anybody under any circumstances. And then a couple weeks go by, they realize OK, I guess I'm going to be here for a while. I might as well start getting relaxed. A lot of people come in with suit and tie because they figure they're going to meet with somebody immediately, and then get back into the classroom, because they think this whole thing is a joke. What am I here for in the first place?
这种环境有其独特的文化。当你待得够久——我待了一年——当你待得够久，你就会看到文化的各个阶段。新人坐在那里，非常安静，在任何情况下都不跟任何人说话。然后几周过去了，他们意识到，好吧，我想我得在这里待上一段时间了。我不妨放松一点。很多人穿着西装打着领带进来，因为他们以为会立即见到某人，然后回到教室，因为他们认为这一切都是个笑话。我到底为什么会在这里？
So once it dawns on them that you're going to be here for a while, then they start to loosen up. They don't dress as nice. They realize, I've got to be comfortable because I'm going to be sitting down in a room for six hours. Then on stage three, you start opening up, you start talking to people, you start interacting. What you like? Oh, I like doing crossword puzzles. You start building bonds with people.
所以一旦他们意识到你得在这里待上一段时间，他们就开始放松了。他们穿得没那么讲究了。他们意识到，我得舒服点，因为我要在房间里坐上六个小时。然后到第三阶段，你开始敞开心扉，开始和人交谈，开始互动。你喜欢什么？噢，我喜欢玩填字游戏。你开始和人们建立纽带。
This guy spent a full year in the rubber room. And then he was fired without any formal charges. At any given time there are as many as a dozen or so rubber rooms around the city of New York, in all five boroughs, holding as many as 700 or 800 teachers. Teachers show up every day, all day. And they're paid their full salaries, meaning taxpayers are putting out tens of millions of dollars for this every year.
这家伙在橡皮室里待了一整年。然后他在没有任何正式指控的情况下被解雇了。在任何特定时间，纽约市各地都有多达十几间橡皮室，分布在所有五个行政区，关押着多达700到800名教师。老师们每天整天都出现在那里。他们领着全额工资，这意味着纳税人每年为此支出数千万美元。
Well, this teacher's film about the rubber room made us wonder more about what life is like inside the rubber room. And with the filmmaker's permission, we asked the team at Radio Diaries-- Joe Richman, Samara Freemark, and Anayansi Diaz Cortes-- to go out and do a radio version of the story. Here it is.
嗯，这位老师关于橡皮室的电影让我们对橡皮室内的生活感到更加好奇。在电影制作人的允许下，我们请 Radio Diaries 团队——乔·里奇曼、萨马拉·弗里马克和阿纳扬西·迪亚兹·科尔特斯——去制作这个故事的广播版本。以下就是。
My ?] name is [? Iago Kier ?]. I'm 32 years old. I was an English teacher in the Bronx for three years.
我的名字是伊亚戈·基尔。我32岁。我在布朗克斯做过三年英语老师。
My name is Grace Colon. I've been a teacher in New York City for 16 years. I'm starting my second year in the rubber room.
我的名字是格蕾丝·科隆。我在纽约市当了16年老师。我现在在橡皮室的第二年。
My name is Jonathan. I was a teacher in the New York City public school system for one month and in the rubber room for four months. Yeah. I spent much longer in the rubber room than I did in the classroom.
我的名字是乔纳森。我在纽约市公立学校系统工作了一个月，在橡皮室待了四个月。是的。我在橡皮室待的时间比在教室待的时间长得多。
I ?] was under a lot of stress at work. I was three months into teaching. And I rolled into work that day, it was two days after my 29th birthday. And I was going from group to group, helping them out if they had answers with the prompts, things like that. I'm sitting down with one particular group, and they're all speaking really loudly and I'd not paid attention. And the classroom and turned into a chaos. The next thing I know, I'm screaming, I'm cursing, I am basically unhinged. And I picked up a chair. And I threw it at a blackboard. And I didn't really get a lot of torque on it. I didn't really release it like I wish I could have. And it bounced off a wall and on the way down nicked a student. I then left the classroom. I just couldn't believe what I had done. I went and splashed cold water on my neck. And I just tried to assess just what I had done, you know. I remember going back into the classroom. And to them it was-- well I mean, looking at it objectively, to them, it must have been-- not fun per se-- but hugely entertaining to see an adult, someone in a position of power, completely lose their [BLEEP]. And then the next day, I'm taken out of the classroom and reassigned.
当时我在工作中承受着巨大的压力。我教书才三个月。那天我到了单位，是我29岁生日后的两天。我正在各个小组之间走动，如果他们对题目有疑问就帮帮他们。我和其中一个小组坐在一起，他们说话声音很大，我没太注意。教室里变得混乱起来。接着我发现自己在尖叫，在咒骂，基本上情绪失控了。我拿起一把椅子，扔向了黑板。我没使上多少力。我没有像我希望的那样把椅子扔出去。它撞到墙上弹回来，掉下来时划伤了一个学生。然后我离开了教室。我简直不敢相信自己做了什么。我走过去用冷水泼在脖子上。我试图评估自己刚刚做了什么，你知道。我记得回到教室。客观地看，对他们来说，这肯定不是……即便不是很有趣，看着一个成年人，一个处于权力位置的人，彻底失去理智，也一定是非常有娱乐性的。第二天，我就被调离了教室。
My principal called me into the office just before Christmas, 2006. She had a paper. And she told me that I am being reassigned to a reassignment center. And I'm asking, what does this mean? What does reassignment center mean? Somebody looked at me and said, well, you're in the rubber room.
2006年圣诞节前夕，校长把我叫进办公室。她拿着一份文件。她告诉我，我被重新分配到调职中心。我问，这意味着什么？调职中心是什么意思？有人看着我说，嗯，你在橡皮室里。
I said the word [BLEEP] in the hallway at my school in a conversation with another teacher. And unbeknownst to me, there was an open door nearby, and a classroom of eighth graders heard me. I knew that I was going to be in trouble. The principal pulled me aside on my way to my classroom and charged me with verbal abuse of a child. It's child abuse, verbal abuse. So she literally accused me of abusing a child by accidentally using a single four letter word. And I had no idea at that moment I would never see my students again. I had no idea.
我在学校走廊里和另一位老师交谈时说了句脏话。我不知道附近有一扇开着的门，一间八年级的教室听到了。我知道我会有麻烦。校长在我去教室的路上把我拉到一边，指控我口头虐待儿童。这是虐待儿童，言语虐待。所以她真的指控我因为无意中说了一个四字母单词而虐待了一个孩子。那一刻我根本不知道我将永远见不到我的学生了。我根本不知道。
When I did go to the so-called reassignment center, you walk into a typical city office, almost like either welfare office, food stamp office. People walking around, trying to look busy, not making eye contact. You start thinking, where are you?
当我真的去了所谓的调职中心时，你走进一个典型的城市办公室，简直就像福利办公室、食品券办公室。人们走来走去，假装忙碌，不与人眼神交流。你开始想，这是哪？
And ?] there are about eight to 10 rooms. In every room there are about 10 people. And space is at a premium.
大约有八到十个房间。每个房间大约有10个人。空间非常宝贵。
I mean, you had the black corner, you had the Hispanic corner, you had the few white people that were scared to death. And so you have to make a quick decision, because everybody else is sort of looking you, sizing you up. Where do I go?
我是说，有黑人区，有西班牙裔区，还有几个吓得要死的白人。所以你必须迅速做出决定，因为其他人都在打量你，评估你。我该去哪？
My first day there, I went in and I reported to the supervisor in charge. She said, well go find yourself a chair, but be careful because people are territorial, and, in fact, fights have broken out over chairs. And I thought to myself, what are you talking about? Fights-- people-- fights breaking out among teachers over chairs? And I went and I saw-- the first open seat I saw, I went and I sat down in it. And I opened up my book. And the person next to me said, you can't sit there. That's blah-blah-blah's seat. And I said, well where's blah-blah-blah? He said, well, he didn't come in, because it's Friday and he wanted the three day weekend. And I said, well, when he comes in, we could talk about it then. So she got up and left the room. And a minute later she came back and she said, I found you a seat. I got you a seat. You'll like it better there, I can see you like to read. It's a quieter room. So I thought that's a friendly thing to do. And she went and took me in the other room and she asked my name. And she said, everybody this is Jonathan. And she went around the room. And she introduced me to everyone in the room. And she said, here's your chair. And sure enough, there was an empty chair. And then she left. And I went and I sat down. And the woman a couple of chairs away said, you can't sit there. That's blah-blah-blah's seat.
我第一天去那里，向负责人报告。她说，去给自己找把椅子，但要小心，因为人们是有领地意识的，实际上，还发生过为了抢椅子而打架的事。我心里想，你在说什么？打架——人们——教师之间为了抢椅子而打架？我看到了我看到的第一张空座位，我就坐下了。我翻开了书。旁边的人说，你不能坐那儿。那是某某某的座位。我说，那某某某在哪？他说，他没来，因为今天是周五，他想休个三天的周末。我说，好吧，等他来了我们再谈。她站起来离开了房间。一分钟后她回来了，她说，我帮你找到了一个座位。我帮你找了个座位。你会喜欢那儿的，我看出你喜欢阅读。那是个安静的房间。我想那是个友好的举动。她把我带进另一个房间，问了我的名字。她说，大家，这是乔纳森。她环顾房间，把每一个人都介绍给我。她说，这是你的椅子。果然，有一把空椅子。然后她离开了。我走过去坐下了。旁边几把椅子远的一个女人说，你不能坐那儿。那是某某某的座位。
And I want to emphasize, I was not in a good mood. I was not happy to be there. I didn't know what was going on with me. I was I was feeling hostile. And well, I'm kind of a big guy. And this is a rather petite woman some years older than me. And I leaned right over and I got in her face. I said, now you listen to me. I'm going to sit in that chair. And if anybody doesn't like it, if anybody's got a problem about it, you send them right to me and we'll talk about it. And I sat right down, and I opened my book. And she gave me a dirty look and didn't say anything. So I sat in that very same chair every day. And that was my chair. And sometimes I could get an empty chair and put it in front of me and turn it around and use it as a table. And that was nice.
我得强调，我当时心情不好。我不高兴待在那里。我不知道自己身上发生了什么。我感到充满敌意。我是个大个子，而这是一个比我年长几岁、身材娇小的女人。我直接探身过去，凑到她脸上。我说，你听好了。我要坐在这个座位上。如果有人不喜欢，如果有人对此有意见，让他们直接来找我，我们可以聊聊。我就坐下了，打开了我的书。她狠狠地瞪了我一眼，什么也没说。所以每天我都坐在同一张椅子上。那是我的椅子。有时我可以弄到一把空椅子放在前面，翻过来把它当作桌子用。这感觉不错。
My ?] name is [? Gail Friedman. ?] I am now in the rubber room. And I've been in there since February of 2007. The children don't know what happened to me. They might have thought maybe I moved away or I went to another school. You're just not there anymore.
我的名字是盖尔·弗里德曼。我现在在橡皮室里。我从2007年2月就在那儿了。孩子们不知道我发生了什么。他们可能以为我搬走了或者去了另一所学校。你只是不在那里了。
You're in this forgotten little place. My name is Pete Sinclair, but that's really not my name. And I have been in the rubber room for about a year and a half. It's that feeling of lack of momentum, of anything moving. It's like purgatory. And time just goes by. And everyone is just sort of playing cards.
你在这个被遗忘的小地方。我的名字是皮特·辛克莱，但那其实不是我的名字。我在橡皮室里待了一年半左右。那是一种缺乏动力、没有任何事情进展的感觉。就像炼狱。时间就这样流逝。每个人都只是在玩纸牌。
It's just like you sit and wait. As if you'd be in a waiting room, except that you're waiting for months. Sometimes people wait for years. You just wait.
就像你坐在那儿等。就像你在候诊室，只不过你等了几个月。有时人们等了几年。你只是等。
When I first come in to the rubber room in the mornings, I look at the papers. Then I look through my bag, I usually stick bills and stuff, my checkbook.
早晨我第一次进橡皮室时，我会看报纸。然后翻看我的包，通常我会放些账单之类的，我的支票簿。
You just kind of go there, you sign in, you sit down, you stare at the wall. You get into a conversation with somebody. You make a phone call. You check your stocks if you want.
你只是去那儿，签个到，坐下，盯着墙看。你和某人聊上几句。你打个电话。如果你想的话，可以查查你的股票。
Some people play cards. Some people gossip. Some people have portable VCRs. They look at movies.
有些人玩纸牌。有些人说闲话。有些人带着便携式录像机。他们看电影。
And then there were little classes that were held. I took Spanish classes from a Spanish teacher. There were drawing classes. There was a book club, very popular. And they would meet twice a week for 90 minutes. And you would have 20 people in this little room that housed the refrigerator and the microwave. And they'd be talking about the novel or what have you. But you know, that might be three or four hours a week. Even if you did all the activities, it's just a few hours a week.
然后还有举行一些小班课。我从一位西班牙语老师那里上了西班牙语课。还有绘画课。有一个读书俱乐部，非常受欢迎。他们每周会开两次会，每次90分钟。你会在这个放着冰箱和微波炉的小房间里挤进20个人。他们会谈论小说什么的。但这可能每周只有三四个小时。即使你参加了所有的活动，每周也就几个小时。
And there are a lot of people who would just bring in pillows and would sleep all day.
还有很多人会带枕头进来，睡上一整天。
No lesson plans, no homework, no papers to grade, no dealing with parents, no dealing with screaming kids.
没有教案，没有作业，没有试卷要批改，不用应付家长，不用应付尖叫的孩子。
And indeed there are teachers and reverence for years collecting the salary for a job that they're not doing.
事实上，确实有教师多年来领着工资却不做工作。
And for some people that's not so bad. If you really hated teaching, and you really liked playing cards, the money's the same.
对有些人来说那还不错。如果你真的讨厌教书，又真的喜欢玩纸牌，钱是一样的。
So yeah, the noise for me might have been the worst part of actually being there. And the sound of it was really the most distinctive thing of it. I wanted to get a souvenir. I brought in a little digital voice recorder. So I just laid the recorder down on the table. I'll play it for you.
对我来说，噪音可能是待在那里最糟糕的部分了。声音确实是那里最鲜明的特征。我想留个纪念。我带了一个小数字录音机。我就把它放在了桌子上。我放给你听。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[人声嘈杂]
It's very crowded, the acoustics are terrible, very echoey. And teachers like to talk.
那里非常拥挤，音响效果很差，回声很大。而且老师们喜欢说话。
I agree. We're off from what society condones as the norm.
我同意。我们脱离了社会所认可的常态。
Like at a loud party, where you're talking to somebody and after a while you realize that you're both shouting. And then you realize that everybody in the room is shouting.
就像在吵闹的聚会上，当你和某人谈话时，过了一会儿你意识到你们都在大喊大叫。然后你意识到房间里的每个人都在大喊大叫。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[人声嘈杂]
It's really difficult to sit there and try to read or get anything done when people are yelling, or fighting, or screaming over a missing bottle of jelly in the refrigerator.
当人们在吵闹、打架或为了冰箱里少了一瓶果酱而尖叫时，坐在那儿试图阅读或完成任何事情真的很难。
You have people that are in denial. You have people that are angry. You have people that have shut down. You have people that have introverted into not even speaking. They just come in and exist.
里面有人在否认现实。有人在愤怒。有人已经封闭了自己。有人已经内向到甚至不再说话。他们只是进来存在着。
I mean there are some really nutty people in there.
我的意思是，里面确实有一些疯疯癫癫的人。
You don't want to make eye contact. There have been a lot of fights. The dumbest stuff. Someone went into the refrigerator and stole someone's butter. There have been arguments over paper, over someone stealing someone's pen.
你不想产生眼神接触。发生过很多次打架。都是些最愚蠢的事情。有人进了冰箱偷了别人的黄油。发生过为了纸、为了有人偷了别人的笔而产生的争吵。
Some of the people in the room like the lights off because it's more restful and maybe they even want to sleep. And the rest of the people want the lights on, because they want to read or play cards. So somebody will get up and turn the lights off. And somebody else will get up and turn the lights back on. It's a conflict of wills.
房间里有些人喜欢关灯，因为这样更舒适，也许他们甚至想睡觉。而剩下的人想开灯，因为他们想看书或玩纸牌。所以有人会起来关灯。而另一个人会起来把灯打开。这是意志的冲突。
There were fights, a couple of fights. I heard them because they'd be going on, say, in the room next door in the hallway, and then everybody would spill out into the hallway to go watch.
发生过打架，几次打架。我听到了，因为它们可能发生在隔壁房间或走廊里，然后每个人都会涌到走廊去看。
It's a prison type of culture. If you go out of your comfort zone then people will mess with you. Let's say if I were to go to the white area and decide I want their chair and stuff. The people there are going to look out for their chairs. And so there will be a confrontation. You want to be very careful not to step on anybody's space, because space seems to be the last control. That's the last thing they have control over.
这是一种监狱文化。如果你离开了你的舒适区，人们就会找你麻烦。比方说，如果我去了白人区域，决定要他们的椅子之类的东西。那边的人会照顾好他们的椅子。所以会发生对抗。你一定要非常小心，不要踩到任何人的空间，因为空间似乎是最后的控制权。那是他们拥有的最后一点掌控力。
People fight over the few things that there are to fight over, such as territory. It's this amazing thing because one of the more popular members of the group went back to her school. She got sent back. And there were literally tearful farewells. There were flowers. There was cake. Goodbye, goodbye. And before the end of the day, somebody had claimed her seat. And everybody had kind of moved up in the pecking order, territorially. It's not so much the chair as it is the real estate it sits upon. So what you want is a nice spot. It's nice to sit near a window. It makes a difference whether there's some shrieking banshee four feet away from your ear. It makes a difference whether the light fixture flickers. I mean, you're going to be there for seven hours a day, five days a week. You wouldn't think it would make so much of a difference. But you're there for a long time, so it does.
人们为了仅有的几件值得争夺的东西而打架，比如领地。这真是太神奇了，因为团队里其中一位受欢迎的成员回到了她的学校。她被送回去了。真的有泪流满面的告别。有鲜花。有蛋糕。再见，再见。而在当天结束之前，已经有人占据了她的座位。每个人都在领地等级上向上移动了一些。与其说是为了椅子，不如说是为了它所处的地段。所以你想要一个好的位置。坐在窗边很好。坐在四英尺外有一个尖叫的女妖旁边，这感觉完全不同。灯具是否闪烁也大不相同。我是说，你要在那里每天待七个小时，每周五天。你不会想到这会有多大区别。但你在那里待了很久，所以这确实有区别。
The ?] strangest feeling is getting up in the morning with a purpose-- taking a shower, brushing your teeth, having that first cigarette, getting on the train, dealing with all these commuters-- to show up to work to do nothing. And I think I think it's made that way. I think that's kind of the point. They punish you with boredom.
最奇怪的感觉是早起有个目标——洗澡、刷牙、抽第一支烟、上火车、应付所有这些通勤者——去上班，却什么都不做。我认为这是故意这样设计的。他们用无聊来惩罚你。
It's kind of an indelicate question to ask somebody how long they've been there. It's a little bit like asking somebody what they're in for. It's embarrassing. It's humiliating.
问别人待了多久是一个有些冒昧的问题。这有点像问别人因为什么被关进来。这很尴尬。这很羞耻。
After ?] about a week of going there and reading all day, you begin to realize that there is no cavalry. There is no one coming in your defense. There's no one beating down the door, saying, give us back our teacher. There's no one making phone calls to clear your name. And that's when it hits you. That's when you realize, holy crap, I could be here indefinitely.
在那里待了一周并整天阅读后，你开始意识到没有援军。没有人会来为你辩护。没有人会撞开门说，把我们的老师还给我们。没有人打电话来洗清你的名字。就在那时，你意识到了。就在那时你意识到，天哪，我可能被无限期关在这里了。
When you first start out, you're in denial. And you're sort of frozen. You have no emotion. I think that went on for me for maybe two to three months. And then after six months, at that point we had our summer vacation. You come back, and then you get angry all over again. Here you are, starting again, yet a new school semester, in this limbo.
你刚开始时是在否认。你处于冻结状态。你没有任何情绪。我想对我来说这种情况持续了两到三个月。然后六个月后，那时我们有了暑假。你回来，然后你又重新感到愤怒。你又开始了，又是一个新的学校学期，在这个窘境中。
The thing with the Department of Education, it's such a large system. A million kids, a million students. If you begin to think about it, it's staggering.
关于教育局，它是一个如此庞大的系统。一百万个孩子，一百万名学生。如果你开始想这件事，它是惊人的。
There are 70,000 teachers. So even if 700 have these Kafka-esque things happening to them, that's still only one in 100. Wait, that is a lot. 1%.
有7万名教师。所以即使有700人遇到了这种卡夫卡式的事情，那也只有百分之一。等等，那确实很多。1%。
I feel that the Department of Education, in many ways, is hiding a secret. The rubber room.
我觉得教育局在许多方面都在隐瞒一个秘密。橡皮室。
I certainly hear the term rubber room thrown around. I use the phrase reassignment center. Temporary reassignment center. My name is Dan Weisberg. I'm the chief executive labor policy for the New York City Department of Education. I don't doubt that there are teachers in the reassignment centers who believe, A, they didn't do anything wrong, or there are teachers there who think that what they did really doesn't warrant the punishment, as they see it, of being reassigned. In some cases those are difficult decisions. But we are entrusted with the safety of over a million kids, including, by the way, mine. The benefit of the doubt has to go to the kids. We're not an auto company. We're not an accounting firm. We're dealing with something unique, and that is the well being of children.
我当然听到过“橡皮室”这个词。我使用“调职中心”这个说法。临时调职中心。我的名字是丹·魏斯伯格。我是纽约市教育局首席劳工政策官。我不怀疑在调职中心有一些教师认为，A，他们没做错什么，或者有教师认为他们所做的实际上并不值得被重新分配的惩罚。在某些情况下，这些决定很难。但我们肩负着超过一百万个孩子的安全，顺便说一下，其中也包括我的孩子。怀疑的利益必须给予孩子们。我们不是汽车公司。我们不是会计师事务所。我们处理的是独特的东西，那就是儿童的福祉。
My sense is that there's been a more aggressive policy about trying to bring teachers up on charges, and as a result the numbers of people going into the rubber room have increased a lot lately. I'm Sam Freedman and I write the On Education column for the New York Times. And I've been covering education on and off for about 30 years. There are many incompetent, and some abusive and exploitative teachers who are totally deserving of having their licenses taken away, and who should be never allowed to be in the presence of children.
我的感觉是，有一种更积极的政策试图对教师提出指控，因此最近进入橡皮室的人数增加了很多。我是萨姆·弗里德曼，我为《纽约时报》撰写教育专栏。我断断续续报道教育新闻大约30年了。有很多不称职，甚至虐待和剥削学生的教师，他们完全应该被吊销执照，并且绝不应该被允许出现在孩子面前。
That said, this is still not the humane way to deal with them. And it has also, in my view, not been an effective way of separating out who's facing legitimate accusations and who's there because of a grudge with a principal and is otherwise an entirely capable educator. There isn't a whole lot they can do about it, except to have their day in court, or more exactly, have their date with a hearing officer.
话虽如此，这仍然不是对待他们的人道方式。在我看来，这也并不是一种有效的分离方式，无法区分谁是面临合理的指控，谁是因为与校长的私人恩怨才来到这里，而实际上是一位完全有能力的教育工作者。除了在法庭上见，或者更准确地说，与听证官见面，他们对此无能为力。
I'm starting my second year in the rubber room. I'm waiting to have my hearing.
我现在进入橡皮室第二年了。我在等听证会。
My case was very, very different. In my case, I had a principal who was willing to go to bat for me. After two weeks I was reinstated and allowed to come back and teach.
我的情况非常、非常不同。在我的案例中，我有一位愿意为我辩护的校长。两周后我就恢复了职务，并被允许回来教书。
Well, I fully expect to be fired. And I've got another job. By most measures it's a better job. I'll make a little more money. I have a little more responsibility. There's more room for advancement. But it's not what I chose. I chose to teach in the public schools. And I don't think I'm going to make the kind of difference in people's lives, doing what I'm going to be doing, that I could have made teaching.
嗯，我完全预料到会被解雇。我已经有了另一份工作。从大多数指标来看，这是一份更好的工作。我会多挣一点钱。我会有更多的责任。有更多的晋升空间。但这并不是我所选择的。我选择在公立学校教书。我不认为做我现在将要做的工作，能像我教书那样在人们的生活中产生那种影响。
Our story on the rubber room was produced by Joe Richman, Samara Freemark, and Anayansi Diaz Cortes of Radio Diaries. Their website, where you can hear their stories for absolutely free, radiodiaries.org. The movie about rubber rooms that inspired us to do this story is at rubberroommovie.com.
我们关于橡皮室的故事是由 Radio Diaries 的乔·里奇曼、萨马拉·弗里马克和阿纳扬西·迪亚兹·科尔特斯制作的。他们的网站 radiodiaries.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听他们的故事。启发我们制作这个故事的关于橡皮室的电影在 rubberroommovie.com。
[MUSIC - "WAITING ROOM" BY FUGAZI]
[音乐 - FUGAZI 的《WAITING ROOM》]
Coming up, in managing the lives of apes for medical research, we have accidentally given them a taste for one TV show, in particular. What that show is in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，在管理类人猿的医学研究生活时，我们不经意间让他们对一部特定的电视节目产生了兴趣。那是什么节目？稍后揭晓。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Human Resources. Stories of the ways that our lives are controlled by managers, bosses, institutions, central offices, home offices, all far away from us. And we've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, The Plan. American cities have gone through a massive wave of gentrification in the last few decades. But to a lot of people, that process does not represent the natural ebb and flow of the real estate market, but something more sinister, more orchestrated. It's a plot, and they are its targets. One of our producers, Jon Jeter, headed to the changing neighborhoods of Washington, DC, to try to get a picture of how people see this particular plot.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来围绕该主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，《人力资源》。讲述了我们的生活如何被经理、老板、机构、总部，所有离我们很远的人所掌控的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，计划。在过去的几十年里，美国城市经历了一波大规模的绅士化浪潮。但对许多人来说，这一过程并不代表房地产市场的自然涨落，而是更险恶、更精心策划的事情。这是一个阴谋，而他们就是目标。我们的制作人之一，乔恩·杰特，前往正在变化的华盛顿特区社区，试图描绘人们如何看待这个特定的阴谋。
John Burroughs Elementary is one of those public schools that parents feel lucky to have in their neighborhood. Maria Jones lives right across the street from the school in the northeast corridor of Washington, DC. And her daughter is in kindergarten here.
约翰·伯勒斯小学是那些家长觉得能在这个社区里拥有一所感到幸运的公立学校之一。玛丽亚·琼斯就住在华盛顿特区东北走廊学校的街对面。她的女儿就在这里上幼儿园。
We have a great principal, wonderful teachers, everybody knows one another. The parents work well, an active PTA body. We love this school.
我们有一位伟大的校长，出色的老师，每个人都互相认识。家长们工作配合默契，家长教师协会非常活跃。我们爱这所学校。
But a few months ago, Maria and other parents were at the school for career day when they heard the news. The mayor was going to close 23 public schools, including theirs. And what was shocking were the reasons the mayor gave: falling enrollment and poor performance. Enrollment isn't falling at Burroughs, Maria says.
但几个月前，玛丽亚和其他家长在学校参加职业日时听到了这个消息。市长要关闭23所公立学校，包括他们这一所。而令人震惊的是市长给出的原因：入学人数下降和表现不佳。伯勒斯学校的入学人数并没有下降，玛丽亚说。
Our enrollment has been building. And then the other thing, failing test scores. We are not failing at all. We are 15th in reading out of 81 District of Columbia public elementary schools. We are in the top 20 percentile in math out of all 81 elementary schools.
我们的入学人数一直在增加。还有一点，考试成绩不佳。我们根本没有失败。在哥伦比亚特区81所公立小学中，我们的阅读成绩排在第15位。在所有81所小学中，我们的数学成绩在排名前20%。
And so the question is, why would they want to close the school, which the neighborhood seems to enjoy, which is sort of an anchor?
所以问题是，他们为什么要关闭这所社区似乎很喜欢，而且是一种锚点一样的学校呢？
It's an anchor. Isn't it beautiful?
它是一个锚点。不是很美吗？
It's a beautiful school from what I can see.
据我所知，这是一所美丽的学校。
What the community is saying is that it must be a land grab. Because if you look all the way down into 20th Street and all the way down to 18th, this is one beautiful long block. And then we have this great green field that's just there for kids to play on. And everybody knows that the developers have converged upon DC and are just going after the property that they want. So this has got to be one of those scenarios. What else can it be? We're not failing. We're a model school.
社区的说法是这一定是一场圈地运动。因为如果你一直看向20街和18街，这是一个美丽的街区。而且我们有这块伟大的绿地，就供孩子们玩耍。每个人都知道开发商已经涌向特区，他们只是在追求他们想要的房产。所以这一定是那些剧本中的一个。还能是什么呢？我们没有失败。我们是一所模范学校。
In Washington DC, it's not difficult to find people who believe in something called the plan. The Plan. It is essentially a conspiracy theory, dating back at least 40 years to the '68 riots, when whites fled the city in droves, leaving behind a black majority. Some people, white and black, have for years written off the plan as paranoia. But residents like Maria look around and see new homes and new shops, and new neighbors, and-- this seems to be the litmus test for whether your neighborhood is gentrifying-- white couples walking their dogs. They never saw that before.
在华盛顿特区，不难找到相信一种叫做“计划”的东西的人。“计划”。这本质上是一个阴谋论，至少可以追溯到40年前的68年骚乱，当时白人成群结队地逃离城市，留下了黑人多数。一些人，白人和黑人，多年来一直把这个计划斥为偏执。但像玛丽亚这样的居民环顾四周，看到新的住宅和新的商店，新的邻居，而且——这似乎是你的社区是否在绅士化的试金石——遛狗的白人夫妇。他们以前从未见过。
It doesn't seem like a conspiracy, some hidden conspiracy. It seems like an out and out plan for displacement. Especially when you have other buildings-- like the Pierce School, Lovejoy, and some of the other buildings-- that have been turned into condos, that have clearly been closed as schools and opened up with the same structure as million dollar condos that people are living in now.
这看起来不像一个阴谋，某种隐藏的阴谋。这看起来就像一个彻底的流离失所计划。特别是当你看到其他建筑——比如皮尔斯学校、洛夫乔伊学校以及其他一些建筑——已经被改造成公寓时，它们显然是作为学校关闭的，而现在的结构和人们居住的百万美元公寓是一样的。
You don't just hear this kind of talk in DC. In fact, all across the country, if you're black and older than, say, 20, chances are you've heard of some shadowy scheme in your city to move blacks out of certain neighborhoods and whites in.
你不仅在特区听到这种言论。事实上，在全国各地，如果你是黑人并且年龄超过，比方说20岁，你很有可能听说过你所在城市的一些阴暗计划，旨在把黑人从某些社区赶走，让白人搬进来。
My dad has been telling me this for years. I am 44 years old. I can remember when I was growing up my dad would always say, well you know, Valerie, there's a plan. There's a plan.
我父亲多年来一直告诉我这个。我44岁了。我记得我长大的时候，我父亲总是说，你知道，瓦莱丽，有一个计划。有一个计划。
Valerie Leonard grew up on Chicago's south side, in a neighborhood called Lawndale, where she still lives and fights against gentrification.
瓦莱丽·伦纳德在芝加哥南区一个叫朗代尔的社区长大，她现在仍然住在那儿，并与绅士化做斗争。
He was saying this in the '60s and the '70s. You know, this may be a black neighborhood now. But there's a plan on the books that they're going to displace black people and push enough people out so that it's only 25% black. And I said, mm-hmm. You wouldn't believe him, because my dad was one of those conspiracy theorists. And lo and behold, I'm an adult now, and everything that he said is coming to fruition.
他在60年代和70年代就这么说了。你知道，现在这可能是一个黑人社区。但账面上有一个计划，他们要驱逐黑人，把足够多的人赶出去，直到只有25%的黑人。我说，嗯哼。你不会相信他，因为我父亲是那些阴谋论者之一。而看吧，我现在成年了，他所说的一切都在变成现实。
Did your father ever have or share with you any specific details of what he thought was the strategies that the city leaders would adopt to take back this land?
你父亲有没有和你分享过他认为城市领导者会采取什么策略来收回这些土地的具体细节？
I think one of them was planned neglect, that they would just let it run down to nothing, which was true, and let it be overcome with crime. And then once the community runs down, they'll come back and grab the land at a much cheaper price and rebuild it for their own people.
我认为其中之一是计划中的忽视，他们会任由它衰败成虚无，这确实是真的，让它被犯罪所占据。然后一旦社区衰败，他们就会回来以低得多的价格抢占土地，并为他们自己的人重建它。
In New Orleans, Edmond Louis remembers talk of a conspiracy back in the '70s, when he was in elementary school, shortly after the city elected its first black mayor.
在新奥尔良，埃德蒙·路易斯记得70年代的一场阴谋论，当时他还在小学，就在城市选举出第一位黑人市长后不久。
Yeah, there were community activists who were invited into the school. I remember some of the Black Panthers in New Orleans visiting the school. And yeah, they talked about how whites definitely wanted the city back, they wanted control. I remember Reverend Avery C. Alexander, one of the pioneers of the civil rights movement in New Orleans and an activist minister who-- he came to the school. And he said there are some beautiful homes in the neighborhood where the school is, and basically that they want to move young white professionals into this neighborhood and move black people out.
是的，有社区活动家被邀请到学校。我记得一些新奥尔良的黑豹党成员访问过学校。是的，他们谈到了白人是如何一定要收回城市，他们想要控制权。我记得艾弗里·C·亚历山大牧师，新奥尔良民权运动的先驱之一，也是一位激进的牧师——他来到学校。他说，学校所在的社区里有一些美丽的住宅，基本上他们想把年轻的白人专业人士搬进这个社区，把黑人搬出去。
Marcel Diallo was born in 1972 in the Bay Area and remembers rumors of a white takeover of Oakland.
马塞尔·迪亚洛1972年出生在湾区，记得关于白人接管奥克兰的传言。
And some of the things that I was hearing as early as the '80s, back in the crack era, was that-- all the elders in my family would always say, oh, you think they're paving that road for us? You think they're fixing that park for us? The white people got their eye on this place. And they're coming back. That was like urban lore. That was the folklore growing up, that white people one day were going to return and try to kick us out.
早在80年代，在可卡因时代，我听到的一些事情就是——我家里所有的长辈总是说，噢，你以为他们是为了我们铺那条路吗？你以为他们是为了我们修理那个公园吗？白人盯着这个地方。他们要回来了。那就像城市传说。那是成长的民间传说，即白人有一天会回来并试图把我们踢出去。
On a bitterly cold Saturday morning in January, about 60 protesters marched to the home of Washington, DC City Council member, Carol Schwartz, who hasn't been helping them slow gentrification in the city. In the crowd I meet Jabari Zakiya who believes-- has always believed, truth be told-- that DC's mayor and elected officials receive their marching orders from congressional and business leaders in the city.
在1月一个寒冷刺骨的周六早晨，大约60名抗议者游行到华盛顿特区市议会议员卡罗尔·施瓦茨的家，她并没有帮助他们减缓城市的绅士化。在人群中，我遇到了贾巴里·扎基亚，他相信——说实话，他一直相信——特区的市长和民选官员接受来自国会和城市商业领袖的指令。
I almost really believe, literally, that when these city council people get close to being elected-- because DC is basically a democratic town. If you win the primary, you're going to win, right? So they see who's going to win the primary. And they get that little call at night, saying look, we want to see you. And they take you to that little room and sit you down, say look, this is the deal.
我几乎真的相信，字面上地，当这些市议会成员接近当选时——因为特区基本上是一个民主党城市。如果你赢了初选，你就会赢，对吧？所以他们看谁会赢初选。然后他们晚上接到那个小电话，说听着，我们想见你。他们把你带到那个小房间让你坐下，说听着，这就是交易。
Over the past decade, cities like DC, Chicago, Oakland and New Orleans have embarked on what is essentially a fire sale. Schools, libraries, public housing, all of which have been auctioned off and converted into condos, lofts, charter schools, sushi bars, and sports stadiums. Washington, DC's changing demographics have ushered in the first white majority on the city council since Congress approved home rule for Washington more than 30 years ago. But even someone like Jabari, who firmly believes in the plan, doesn't see it as simply a matter of white versus black.
在过去十年里，像特区、芝加哥、奥克兰和新奥尔良这样的城市已经开始了一场本质上的清仓甩卖。学校、图书馆、公共住房，所有这些都被拍卖并改建成了公寓、阁楼、特许学校、寿司吧和体育场馆。华盛顿特区不断变化的人口结构迎来了自国会30多年前批准华盛顿地方自治以来的首个白人多数市议会。但即使是像贾巴里这样坚定相信计划的人，也不会简单地将其视为白人对黑人的问题。
To me, the black members aren't any much different than the white members. In fact, many of the white ones seem to be more progressive than the black ones. I mean look, we've never had a white mayor.
对我来说，黑人成员和白人成员没什么不同。事实上，许多白人成员似乎比黑人成员更进步。我的意思是看，我们从来没有过白人市长。
I think it's the plan of any of those people who want to make money.
我认为这是任何想要赚钱的人的计划。
This is [? Marjorie Rhode, ?] another protester.
这是马乔里·罗德，另一位抗议者。
?] Let us move out the people who are not going to give us profit. And that begins to break right along racial lines. So whether the plan is to move black people out, it doesn't matter. That's the net effect.
让我们把那些不会给我们带来利润的人搬出去。这开始完全沿着种族界线分裂。所以无论计划是否是把黑人搬出去，这不重要。那才是最终结果。
Marjorie is an art professor at the University of the District of Columbia. She has taught there for nearly 30 years and can remember when the enrollment was more than 15,000, triple what it is now. As the enrollment shrinks, the campus shrinks.
马乔里是哥伦比亚特区大学的艺术教授。她在那里教书近30年，还记得入学人数超过15000人的时候，是现在的三倍。随着入学人数缩减，校园也在缩减。
?] That is such a mouth-watering piece of land. So it's hard not to believe that behind closed doors, somebody's really looking at that land. My somewhat paranoid theory, perhaps, is that they're letting the buildings deteriorate. And they're not doing much to support its enrollment. We're not up to date in terms of a lot of our technology and so forth. And then they can say, well, see.
那是一块多么令人垂涎的土地啊。所以很难不相信在闭门会议后，有人真的在盯着那块土地。我有点偏执的理论，也许是，他们正在让建筑恶化。他们对支持入学没有做太多事情。我们在很多技术等方面都没有跟上时代。然后他们可以说，嗯，看吧。
Benign neglect, benign neglect.
良性的忽视，良性的忽视。
No neglect is benign. It's always malignant. And one of the buildings they took was where we had the art department, the music and so forth. Wonderful building, wonderful building. They took us out of it supposedly to renovate it. It is now lofts, condos. OK?
没有忽视是良性的。它总是恶性的。他们拿走的建筑之一就是我们有艺术系、音乐系等的地方。很棒的建筑，很棒的建筑。他们把我们从里面带走，说是为了翻新它。它现在是阁楼，公寓。好了吧？
DC residents point to a group of businessmen called the Federal City Council who have been around since the '50s and who the current mayor says he consults with frequently. Similar business groups exist in other cities. Which seems benign, if you have a certain frame of mind and sinister if you think there's a plan. This much is clear. DC is much different from just a decade ago, when blacks were 64% of the population. Now they're 57%, a huge drop. And everyone believes it won't be long before the city is no longer majority black. People like Charles Brown, a limo driver here, say they believe it's a plot. And he knows that lots of people would think that's crazy. But at this point he says the evidence lines up very much in his favor.
特区居民指着一个叫联邦城市委员会的商人团体，他们从50年代就存在了，现在的市长说他经常咨询他们。其他城市也存在类似的商业团体。如果你有某种心态，这看起来是良性的；如果你认为有一个计划，这就是险恶的。这一点很清楚。特区和仅仅十年前完全不同，当时黑人占人口的64%。现在他们是57%，是一个巨大的下降。每个人都相信用不了多久这座城市将不再是黑人多数。像查尔斯·布朗这样的豪华轿车司机说，他们相信这是一个阴谋。他知道很多人会认为这很疯狂。但在这一点上，他说证据非常支持他的看法。
Just look around. You don't have to believe anything I say. Just look around. That's all you have to do. Just take a look. If you're in Harlem, if you're in Chicago, if you're in New Orleans, if you're in Washington, if you're in LA, I don't care where you are. The plan has worked.
看看四周。你不必相信我说的任何话。看看四周。你只需要这样做。看一看。如果你在哈莱姆，如果你在芝加哥，如果你在新奥尔良，如果你在华盛顿，如果你在洛杉矶，我不在乎你在哪里。这个计划已经奏效了。
Jon Jeter. He's the author of the forthcoming book Flat Broke in the Free Market , about people whose lives are made worse by globalization.
乔恩·杰特。他是即将出版的《在自由市场中身无分文》一书的作者，讲述了生活因全球化而变得更糟的人们的故事。
[MUSIC - "DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT" BY TALKING HEADS]
[音乐 - TALKING HEADS 的《DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT》]
Act Three, Almost Human Resources. Well, all this program we've been talking about how humans manage the lives of other humans. But of course we manage the lives of other species as well. Charles Siebert is a New York Times Magazine writer who is finishing a book right now about a side of this most of us have never heard of, and that when you hear about it, actually sounds like a joke. He's been writing about retirement homes for chimpanzees. Yes. Chimp retirement homes. He's been to all kinds.
第三幕，近乎人力资源。嗯，整个节目我们一直在谈论人类如何管理其他人类的生活。但当然我们也管理其他物种的生活。查尔斯·西伯特是一位《纽约时报杂志》的撰稿人，他现在正在完成一本关于我们大多数人从未听说过的一面的书，当你听到它时，实际上听起来像个笑话。他一直在写关于黑猩猩退休之家的文章。是的。黑猩猩退休之家。他去过各种各样的。
We need them because, first of all, there are over 3,000 chimps in the United States. Now, among those would be pets, entertainers, and former research lab chimpanzees. We have, actually, a surplus of research lab chimps in the United States. And the reason for that is when AIDS was-- the first big outbreak, it was sort of logically assumed that chimps would offer us a possible cure because they share so much of our DNA. That turned out to be bogus. Chimps can't get human AIDS.
我们需要它们，因为首先，美国有超过3000只黑猩猩。其中会有宠物、艺人以及前研究实验室的黑猩猩。我们实际上在美国有剩余的研究实验室黑猩猩。原因是当艾滋病——第一次大爆发时，逻辑上认为黑猩猩会为我们提供可能的治疗方法，因为它们分享了我们如此多的 DNA。事实证明那是假的。黑猩猩不会患上人类艾滋病。
So anyway, we ended up with all these excess breeded chimps that could not be used for AIDS research and for no other research. And so there was this surplus. And the government-- this was near the end of Clinton's administration-- was actually faced with this, I guess, moral, ethical dilemma. What do you do with all these near humans? We can't just euthanize them. And so one of the last acts of the Clinton administration was the Chimp Act. And they actually came up with the idea to build a government-funded retirement home outside of Shreveport, Louisiana. I went to this place. When I first saw it, I thought this is sort of the Jurassic Park of chip retirement. This is the pinnacle of retirement homes for chimps.
所以总之，我们最终拥有了所有这些无法用于艾滋病研究和其他任何研究的超量繁殖的黑猩猩。所以就有了这种剩余。政府——这是克林顿政府末期——实际上面临着这个，我想，道德、伦理困境。你怎么处理所有这些近乎人类的东西？我们不能只是安乐死它们。所以克林顿政府最后的法案之一是《黑猩猩法案》。他们实际上提出了建立一个政府资助的退休之家的想法，在路易斯安那州什里夫波特郊外。我去了那个地方。当我第一次看到它时，我想这就像黑猩猩退休的侏罗纪公园。这是黑猩猩退休之家的巅峰之作。
OK, more on that place-- it's called Chimp Haven-- in just a minute. Charles Siebert says that it's not just research chimps who are getting this treatment. At this point, we know so much more than we used to about how similar chimps brains are to ours-- what they feel, and what they know, and how much like us they really are-- that they have become an animal that we usually do not ever euthanize. Which, when you think about how nearly every other animal of the animal kingdom that we have contact with, we feel utterly free to kill at whim, en masse, is very unusual. But then, of course, we get into this problem. If we're not going to kill the chimps after they cease to be useful to us, where should we keep them? Under what conditions? Consider the problem of chimpanzees who work in the entertainment business, who perform in the circus, or appear on TV commercials, or in movies. Here is something that most of us do not know about chimp entertainers.
好的，关于那个地方——它被称为“黑猩猩天堂”——稍后再详细介绍。查尔斯·西伯特说，不仅仅是研究黑猩猩在接受这种待遇。此时，我们比过去更了解黑猩猩的大脑与我们的相似程度——它们的感受，它们知道什么，它们有多像我们——以至于它们已经成为我们通常绝不安乐死的动物。当你想到我们接触的几乎所有其他动物王国里的动物，我们都觉得可以随意杀死它们，大规模地杀戮，这非常不寻常。但当然，我们陷入了这个难题。如果我们在它们不再对我们有用后不杀死它们，我们应该把它们养在哪里？在什么条件下？考虑一下在娱乐业工作、在马戏团表演、或出现在电视广告或电影中的黑猩猩的问题。这里是我们大多数人不知道的关于黑猩猩艺人的事情。
These chimps have about a 4 to 5 year period of viability as actors. And then they just get too strong, too willful, too out of control.
这些黑猩猩作为演员有大约4到5年的生存期。然后它们就变得太强壮、太任性、太失控。
And is that because 4 or 5 is when they hit adolescence or something? Like, that's when they become adult, and before that they're just little kids, basically?
这是因为4或5岁是它们进入青春期还是什么吗？就像，那是它们成为成年人的时候，而在此之前它们基本上只是小孩子？
Precisely. A chimpanzee, a full grown adult chimpanzee, is five times as strong as a human man. And especially male chimps are very, very volatile, and competitive, and aggressive. So for that one or two yuks that we get on television, they then spend another 40 to 50 years locked up somewhere because they're no longer usable.
正是如此。一只黑猩猩，一只完全成年的黑猩猩，力量是人类男性的五倍。而且特别是雄性黑猩猩非常、非常易怒、好胜且具有攻击性。所以为了我们在电视上获得的那一两次欢笑，它们随后要在某个地方被锁起来四五十年，因为它们不再可用了。
So these are chimps, basically, who've been working in the human working world. And when they retire, I know there's a discussion about how much we should try to re-chimp them.
所以这些基本上是曾在人类工作世界中工作的黑猩猩。当它们退休时，我知道关于我们应该多大程度上尝试让它们恢复“黑猩猩本性”有一个讨论。
Yes.
是的。
And can you just talk about the range of solutions that people have come up with to that problem? The different ways people think about that, the different ways these different retirement homes are set up. What's the range of things that you've seen?
你能谈谈人们为了解决这个问题想出的各种解决方案吗？人们对这件事的不同思考方式，这些不同的退休之家是如何设置的。你看到的范围有多广？
These are chimps that, the official word used is they've been inculturated. A lot of them have been eating off of caterers' tables, been only around humans. And they like us. They're very social animals and, especially if we're imprinted on them very early, they form very tight bonds. So the gradations would be-- I guess, the one extreme would be Cheeta's life. That would seem sort of like the human paradigm, a retirement home in Palm Springs, riding around in golf carts.
这些黑猩猩，官方说法是它们已经被“融入人类文化”。它们很多一直吃着餐饮承办商的餐桌，只和人类在一起。它们喜欢我们。它们是非常社会化的动物，特别是如果我们很早就在它们身上打下了烙印，它们会形成非常紧密的纽带。所以等级会是——我猜，最极端的是 Cheeta 的生活。那看起来像是人类的典范，棕榈泉的退休之家，坐着高尔夫球车转悠。
You mean Cheeta from the Tarzan films?
你是说《人猿泰山》电影里的 Cheeta？
Yes, who is 75 now, although there is some dispute about whether he is actually that old. He's at a retirement home in Palm Springs. He was walking around the house. We sat out back by the swimming pool at a picnic table. He was eating Doritos and drinking diet iced tea. He's a diabetic. He goes into the living room, sits at the piano, bangs on the keys. There's a selection of his movies on the living room coffee table. And he has been given to watching his old movies on TV. He recognizes scenes. He gets up and he claps. He remembers.
是的，它现在75岁了，尽管对于它是否真的那么老存在一些争议。它在棕榈泉的一个退休之家。它在屋子里走来走去。我们坐在后院游泳池旁的野餐桌旁。它在吃多力多滋，喝低卡冰茶。它患有糖尿病。它走进客厅，坐在钢琴前，敲击琴键。咖啡桌上有一系列它的电影。它已经习惯在电视上看它以前的老电影。它认得出场景。它站起来鼓掌。它记得。
He's basically living like the aging Bob Hope.
它基本上过着像步入晚年的鲍勃·霍普一样的生活。
Exactly. There's the one extreme. The humanoid version of chimp retirement. The opposite extreme would be the Center for Great Apes in Florida, where all the retired ape actors are. Or ape entertainers. Circus, TV, movies, and some pets. You have, basically, caged farce. You have these geodesic dome-like structures-- very tall and elaborate, and spacious-- where the chimps are nearly swinging through the trees. The whole ethos of that place, I suppose, would be that they're trying to get them as close back to a state of wild chimpdom as is possible.
正是如此。这是一种极端。黑猩猩退休的人类化版本。相反的极端将是佛罗里达的大猿中心，所有退休的猿类演员都在那里。或者猿类艺人。马戏团、电视、电影和一些宠物。你基本上拥有的是“笼中闹剧”。你拥有这些类似大地穹顶的结构——非常高、复杂且宽敞——黑猩猩几乎是在树间穿梭。那个地方的全部精神，我想，就是他们试图让它们尽可能回归到野生黑猩猩的状态。
OK, so you have the caged farce like that on the one hand, and the nearly Bob Hope style retirement at the other extreme. And then there's this third approach to chimp retirement, the approach that they take at the multimillion dollar facility the government built for research chimps, mostly, outside of Shreveport, Louisiana, Chimp Haven. There chimps live a hybrid sort of retirement, part chimp, part human.
好的，所以你一方面拥有那种笼中闹剧，另一方面是近乎鲍勃·霍普风格的退休。然后还有第三种黑猩猩退休的方法，政府为研究黑猩猩建造的耗资数百万美元的设施所采取的方法，主要在路易斯安那州什里夫波特郊外，黑猩猩天堂。在那里黑猩猩过着混合型的退休生活，部分黑猩猩，部分人类。
It has bedrooms with swinging cots and patios. And they have in their rooms television, VCRs, CDs. And access through these little walkways to little moated forests. It's the most strange blend of the urban and the wild.
它有带秋千床和露台的卧室。它们的房间里有电视、录像机、光盘。通过这些小走道可以进入带护城河的小森林。这是城市与野生最奇怪的混合。
And you asked earlier about gradations of repatriation of chimps. Some of these chimps were born in captivity. Some were taken from the wild. And at Chimp Haven, what they try to do is get the remaining wild ones together with the totally captive born ones, so that the wild ones can teach the captive ones how to be chimps again. Some of the captive ones don't even know what a tree is. Some of the research ones have not even been around ground. They've been in cement cells all their lives, getting shots of different diseases. So they get released and they-- there's this one video I saw of a chimp who had never been on the earth before. And he wouldn't get out of his crate. He was touching down on the earth as though it were the moon. It was the most bizarre thing to see.
你刚才问了关于黑猩猩遣返的等级。一些黑猩猩是在圈养中出生的。一些是从野外带走的。而在黑猩猩天堂，他们试图做的是把剩下的野生黑猩猩和完全在圈养中出生的放在一起，这样野生的可以教圈养的如何再次成为黑猩猩。一些圈养的甚至不知道树是什么。一些研究用的甚至没有接触过地面。它们一生都待在水泥牢房里，接受各种疾病的注射。所以它们被释放，然后它们——我看到过一段视频，关于一只从未接触过大地的黑猩猩。它不愿走出笼子。它触碰大地的样子就像那是月球。看到这一点是最离奇的事情。
So what kind of success do they end up having, in getting those chimps to do those things, to climb trees and to acclimate to those chimp-like behaviors?
那么在让那些黑猩猩做那些事情，爬树并适应那些类似黑猩猩的行为方面，他们最终取得了什么样的成功？
Tremendous success, actually. Over time, these chimps do very well. Have these days oddly bifurcated by chimp activities and human activities, and they live out a life of that kind of to and fro, between the two.
其实非常成功。随着时间的推移，这些黑猩猩做得很好。日子被黑猩猩活动和人类活动奇怪地一分为二，它们就在这两者之间来回穿梭中生活。
So going from what sort of thing to what sort of thing?
所以是从什么样的生活到什么样的生活？
Well they have access to their little pie-shaped five acre wedges of forest. So they're out there swinging in the trees, and socializing with one another, and even doing a little crude form of food gathering.
嗯，它们可以使用它们那五英亩大的馅饼形森林小块。所以它们在那儿在树上荡来荡去，彼此社交，甚至进行一点原始形式的食物搜集。
They're food gathering, you mean the staff hides food out in the middle of the fake forest?
它们进行食物搜集，你是说工作人员把食物藏在假森林中间吗？
They try to grow certain things in the forest that's conducive to things chimps would-- you know, fruits and berries, that kind of thing. But not really enough to sustain them, so they come back in for dinner. And meals, I mean they come for their three squares, which they have been used to getting. So that, to me, is a two-tiered kind of a day. Where you're playing chimp in the jungle, but you're coming back for dinner and watching some television. And these chimps are all inculturated. They've been around medical labs. They've been around doctors and researchers in white coats. So guess what their favorite television show is. General Hospital. So yes, they have access to the woods where they can go be chimps. But they like coming back to their room and watching television and being around people. So they're having this balance. And at one point, I said, so in a way, what you're saying to me is, it would be just as cruel to now fully excerpt them from human contact, given their history. And they said, yeah. They still need access to what they knew as they were reared.
他们试图在森林里种植某些对黑猩猩有益的东西——你知道，水果和浆果之类的。但不足以维持它们的生活，所以它们回来吃晚饭。而用餐，我是说它们来吃它们习惯的三餐。对我来说，那是双重的一天。你像黑猩猩一样在丛林里玩耍，但你要回来吃晚饭，还要看电视。而且这些黑猩猩都受过“人类文化”熏陶。它们一直待在医疗实验室周围。它们一直待在穿着白大褂的医生和研究人员周围。所以猜猜它们最喜欢的电视节目是什么。综合医院。所以是的，它们可以使用树林去当黑猩猩。但它们喜欢回到房间看电视并和人在一起。所以它们取得了这种平衡。在某一点上，我说，所以某种程度上，你对我说的是，考虑到它们的历史，现在完全把它们从人类接触中剥离出来也是一种残忍。他们说，是的。它们仍然需要接触它们成长过程中所了解的东西。
When you describe it this way, it sounds actually kind of like a nice life. They get to do some chimp things, they get to do some human things. Is that OK, or do you feel like somehow we've denatured them, or there's something wrong with this?
当你这样描述它时，听起来实际上是一种不错的生活。它们可以做一些黑猩猩做的事，也可以做一些人类做的事。这样可以吗，还是你觉得我们某种程度上已经让它们“去自然化”了，或者这有什么不对劲的地方？
Well, I've come to feel that it's the best we can do for them, given the circumstances. But in the best of worlds it should have never happened, that they just shouldn't be kidnapped from their lives for these purposes. And they live longer lives in captivity, but they're wild animals and they have their life. And in the course of doing this book and other articles, I've been in the wild and had a chance to see them in the wild.
嗯，我开始觉得考虑到目前的情况，这是我们能为它们做的最好的事了。但在最好的世界里，这永远不应该发生，它们就不应该为了这些目的被绑架离开它们的生活。它们在圈养中寿命更长，但它们是野生动物，它们有它们的生活。在做这本书和其他文章的过程中，我曾经去过野外，有机会在野外看到它们。
Yeah, and when you see that, what do you see?
是的，当你看到那个时，你看到了什么？
I don't know. You feel a very deep stirring. I was running for hours through the woods and just hearing rampant chimp screams. Pods moving, they move with unbelievable felicity through the jungle, really fast. So I began to despair of ever catching up to them. And then suddenly, my guide put this quiet gesture in front of his mouth and pointed up. And there was a mother and a baby about 50 feet up high in a tree, and the baby is staring down at me. And I don't know. I just got chills. It just took my breath away. And I thought about it a lot afterwards, what that kind of meant. It really was very moving.
我不知道。你感觉到一种非常深刻的悸动。我在树林里跑了几个小时，只是听到猖獗的黑猩猩尖叫声。群体移动，它们在丛林中以难以置信的敏捷性移动，真的很快。所以我开始绝望于永远追不上它们。然后突然，我的向导在嘴前做了一个安静的姿势，指了指上方。有一只母亲和婴儿在树上约50英尺高的地方，婴儿正盯着我看。我不知道。我只是感到一阵寒意。它简直让我屏住了呼吸。之后我思考了很多，那意味着什么。它真的很感人。
Charles Siebert. The book he's writing about the weeks that moved into a chimp retirement community is called The Wauchula Woods Accord.
查尔斯·西伯特。他正在写的那本关于进入黑猩猩退休社区的几周的书叫《瓦丘拉森林协定》。
Our program was produced today by our senior producer Julie Snyder and myself, with Alex Blumberg Jane Feltes, Jon Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Our production manager is Seth Lind. Production help today from Emily Youssef and Andy Dixon. Musical help from Jessica Hopper.
我们今天的节目由我们的高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·费尔特斯、乔恩·杰特、萨拉·凯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥韦茨运营我们的网站。我们的生产经理是塞思·林德。今天的制作帮助来自艾米莉·尤塞夫和安迪·迪克森。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
Thanks today to Jeremy Garrett and Justin Cegnar of Five Boroughs Productions. Thanks to George Saunders, and Sean McDonald, and [? Anahi Delany, ?] to [? Zane El Amin ?], and Parisa Norouzi, and Professor Eddie Glaude, Jr., to Empower DC, who helped us with our story about the plan. Their website, empowerdc.org.
感谢今天的杰里米·加勒特和五区制片公司的贾斯汀·塞格纳。感谢乔治·桑德斯、肖恩·麦克唐纳和阿纳希·德莱尼，感谢赞恩·埃尔·阿明、帕丽莎·诺鲁齐和埃迪·格劳德教授，感谢 Empower DC，他们帮助我们完成了关于计划的故事。他们的网站 empowerdc.org。
Our website, where tickets have just gone on sale for our next live show. This is going to be broadcast from a stage in New York to movie theaters all over the country, so you can see it in your town. That is going to happen on April 23. Tickets just went on sale. Go to our website, www.thisamericanlife.org to get your tickets.
我们的网站，我们下一次现场演出的门票刚刚开始发售。这将从纽约的舞台广播到全国各地的电影院，所以你可以在你的城镇看到它。那将于4月23日举行。门票刚刚开始发售。访问我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org 获取门票。
This American life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who-- I've never understood this. He calls me into the office every single episode of the show that we do. And he always begins the same way.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他——我从来没搞懂这一点。他几乎每期节目都把我叫进办公室。而且他总是以同样的方式开始。
Ira, this is going to be a difficult conversation. I want to let you know that up front.
艾拉，这将是一次艰难的谈话。我想先让你知道这一点。
I don't know what he's driving at. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我不知道他想表达什么。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。